top of the morning to you ladies today
is the only sunny day that we will ever
get in uk
so i decided i'm just gonna vlog it
and take some time off from the computer
i'm also wearing shorts i know
very nice mars i've been wanting to buy
uh one of those kiddie pools
for a long time and i'm kind of like
that's a bit trashy but
it sounds fun so we're gonna buy a pool
today to really enjoy the british summer
for those of you who don't know this is
my temporary setup
i'm at our kind of like summer location
and this is pretty much the same setup i
have
as i brought to japan it all fits in a
in a suitcase
setup tour this is the
this is the camera i got in japan this
one is 4k
so which is why sometimes you see all my
pores
in case anyone is curious this is for
the sound
usually you see every youtuber ever have
like the squares on the wall
the thing is you have to spray those
with like this glue and i used to have
that in my old setup
they don't go away from the wall if you
ever put them on the wall once
they're gonna be there forever and i'm
like i don't want to do that again
so you just get these babies look who it
is
how are you sleeping in this bed
our army fair
and i love a penis you guys want to see
something cute oh yeah i found me
no not you edgar come here
thank you maya for cleaning
bye oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry
hey look who always wants attention just
found the
vacuum how the hell did it get there
which one should we get that's really
the only option
i think that's fine honestly
what about the gladiator game no but
there was one thing
this looks so bad
okay we can get those yeah oh my god my
set you just made a mess
oh my god it's gonna be
me and you can't wait
me and angie oh my god guys
please relax
i forgot to buy a pump
you gonna help me blow it in here i even
remember in the shop i need to buy a
pump
okay so what if i fill the water bed i
mean this water thing with
water hmm you know bill gates has the
famous quote that he'd rather hire
lazy people because they'll figure out a
smart solution to a
problem this is how we do it
yeah yeah yeah no problem as you can see
when i say we have a problem we have a
problem the robot
shoosh go away
go somewhere else okay you do the camera
work
oh god it's coming back it's back for
vengeance
please don't hurt me honestly i'm scared
yeah that's right oh no don't kill me
okay stop
why swim in the water when you can swim
around the water
i just discovered something
what is the hint why is there a hole
there so
yes i may have been blowing inside the
hole that's meant to
release the water whatever
i'm sure glad bill gates is watching
let's fill it up baby don't you dare
no so edgar is terrified of water
but if it i think he's just scared of
waves
this is your favorite song yeah
[Music]
okay we're gonna even though it's a
little bit do you think it's a bad idea
to put boiling water
should be fine you know youtubers they
flex with their pulls
this is what i got oh
so nice
put on more water epic prank on
girlfriend time
this is gonna be lit guys oh my god
that's pretty neat look at that
like little titties that's pretty cool
actually
look at that
look at that ah
you bear
i have all the ammo you know did i hit
here
how i ate your butt oh i got the title
for this video now
amaya hey maya oh
she doesn't see anymore she's getting
one blind hey maya
okay catch
is it hard you're usually really good at
catching
slippery no no no no
oh wow it's so hard
okay the water should be a lot harder
now
yeah it's pretty nice actually we're
doing a oh it's nice
i told you we're doing a photo shoot
from hurricane
what's your name again
you know i was number one goalkeeper
[Music]
loves the water so much
that's not too bad yeah
that's not too bad
duke that guy you want to get my [ __ ]
and destiny is mercury
she floats she's so fat oh wait she's
excuse me
good girl good girl she wasn't mine
he's so cute edgar you want to go in
again
i don't like this one
oh my god he's crazy what is he doing
what is happening okay slow mo shot this
is gonna be epic guys
you can't tell but i'm so incredibly
sunburned
i feel it
very nice oh yeah
oh yeah is that an albino bug
or is it just painted to the wall i've
never seen that
i can't believe you notice that you're
such a creep
okay all right buddy all right okay okay
all right i feel like
what do you do just let it go
it's not very good fire
adventures with pewdiepie and marzia
bug catching monsieur do you think i'm
able to put on the wall
[Music]
in case you're wondering it's going it's
going great
it's going so good marcia thinks it's
not straight
well not everything in life is perfect
okay and that's not my fault i messed up
guys i messed up all right tv on the
wall
haters will say it's photoshop what do
you think edgar
if you guys ever need help to hook up
your tv i do installments
youtube revenue is very low please guys
so
any tip will greatly be appreciated i'm
willing to travel
car cross country install your tv
for a cheap price of 3.99
we officially peaked in this vlog it's
not going to get any more interesting
than me putting up a television
there's nothing to vlog i'll uh probably
do some reading
reading starship troopers it's really
good it's nothing like the movie but i
really like it good old relaxing day off
thank you for joining me
i hope you enjoyed this vlog if you want
more vlogs
you know what you gotta do you know what
you gotta do you gotta thumbs
down this video everybody that's right
we do it opposite style on this channel
we're edgy we're cool we're hit please
like the video please i'm just joking